we got up really early this morning in
Accra and we flew to Kumasi which is
where we are now
yeah we're in Kumasi now which is the
it's the cultural capital of Ghana
what's gonna happen today we're gonna go
we're gonna get Kente cloth Kente cloth
yeah which is the traditional like garb
and and then we're gonna meet some
Royals we're gonna meet some of the
Chiefs oh wow yeah the Queen Mother as
well who's the the King's mom right the
Assante him ah you are our guide what is
your name sir I am soccer sock good to
see you how are you I'm very good and
you I'm very good and this is our you
are a weaver and I'm a wee by April my
name is Tommy I've been told that the
Canty cloth has meaning is that right oh
the pentacle fubini's we Revere people
who wears the King T yes so it's
something that everybody wants to have
one yes you've earned the Canty cloth
you should have a Canty cloth I'm a
goofball who's tagging along with you I
feel a little guilty about getting a
kenta class well I know you deserve it
well you don't know that you don't know
what I've done I just want you to see
that's the dog humping my leg
on television that was very recent
there's the dog and he has he's fully
excited when he's something my leg there
I am pretending to be a leprechaun on my
knees so what do you think still maybe I
get a kunti cloth so now is the moment
where we are fitted with our Kente cloth
oh look he's wearing a Red Sox jersey
sir wow that is the Kente cloth of my
people oh wow thank you this is
beautiful oh is that my name yeah this
is this is copyright infringement yeah
I'm suing everyone here you yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
felt in my life I just feel I feel like
I'm finally home
yeah welcome home coming thank you and I
guess you too
you know I think we should do we should
announce right now that we are running
in 2020 yeah we're at the palace we are
about to meet with the Queen Mother and
some cheese shoes and they said bring a
gift bring gifts we asked which gifts
were appropriate you said some schnapps
and some money
and we also brought a ram this is
traditional manisha nops misshape yeah
money schnapps and cheap fare rap song
[Laughter]
it's an honor to be here and an honor to
wear these authentic Ashanti robes
why do you laugh if you like me in the
road do I look good in the road well
excuse me
[Music]
so this wasn't this wasn't working for
you the little little side boob yeah
well shall we cover this too
[Laughter]
[Music]
it's a great honor to come to the great
country of Ghana and meet your beautiful
people
[Applause]